[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultants editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire both with us until just
before midnight so to the front pages
let's start with the metro with the
health secretary encouraging people to
take cover tests before attending
christmas parties the metro proclaims
let it flow let it flow let it flow
the daily mirror follows up its story
yesterday with more details of what it
says went on at the now infamous downing
street christmas party reportedly held
at the height of lockdown last year
the i understands the government has
purchased 114 million
pfizer and moderna booster vaccine doses
that's enough to see the uk through 2023
similar story for the telegraph two more
rounds of booster jabs ordered they say
but according to the guardian ministers
are paving the way to allow gps to stop
monitoring patients with non-covered
underlying conditions in order to
concentrate on the booster effort
the preston journal hears that the
scottish conservative leader douglas
ross is being investigated by the
parliamentary standards commissioner
over the declaration of his earnings he
has apologized and blamed any
irregularities on human error the
financial times reports that the u.s
government is delaying the lifting of
tariffs on uk steel imposed by the trump
administration because of fears over the
implications for post-brexit trade in
northern ireland
well we're joined tonight by andrew
pearce and kevin mcguire welcome back to
you the mood music obviously is omicron
with delta still with high cases how we
limp on or otherwise to christmas via
the christmas party season and the metro
has the answer which is get testing
kevin
yeah let it flow let it flow let it flow
i always like the metro uh headlines
very good front pages but this is the
health secretary sashi javid saying if
you go along to an office party well get
a lateral flow test it might be sensible
equally the working pensions secretary
to his coffee is saying don't snog
anyone you don't normally
kiss under the mistletoe that might be
sensible too but it it shows the uh the
tensions and the pressures if parties
are going ahead which the prime minister
is determined uh they are despite jenny
harry's the chief executive of the uk
health security agency suggesting we
reduce socializing there is there's big
tensions here because it's a huge gamble
and there's alma chronicles but as you
say there's the delta variant there's
just a level of infections and in fact
people are dying at the rate of
a thousand or more per week we're not
out of it uh we're not out of it yet and
uh we're going we're going into
christmas uh the weather's gonna be
worse people are gonna be locked inside
uh have a few drinks uh sometimes they
uh get a bit frisky uh and there is
there is a danger to that we could well
be paid a high price in january and i
guess uh omicron is is there in small
numbers three big questions still to
answer about that that is the
transmissibility of it if it's faster
quicker the severity of it if it causes
more severe illness and the vaccine
escape element and certainly today the
world health organization suggesting
data on transmissibility should be known
within days so not weeks so that's you
know that's a good tick to start with uh
while they still question the booster
program because they obviously want
vaccines to go elsewhere don't they
andrew but you know is the message still
from the government get your booster as
a way of protecting yourself because
delta cases are still really high aren't
they
yeah they are and um they are talking
about boosters it is the story now it's
the only thing that people are talking
about really uh in number 10 and in the
and and i think sanji javid is a blessed
side of relief for this government
actually because
matt hancock who've been health sector
for a very very long time was somewhat
tarnished by the scandal over the number
of people who'd gone from nhs hospitals
into care homes without being tested now
i'm not saying it was his fault but it
happened on his watch and javid comes
with almost he's a is a new broom
sweeping clean and he's he's he's quite
he's a strong media performer i think
he's doing very well and he's quite a
reassuring figure
and um and the fact we've got this
wretched new uh variant that we don't
know how transmissible it's going to be
and we don't know if it's going to be
more serious the world health
organization again saying today thus far
the symptoms are mild but this might
encourage not just people to get their
booster jobs but it might even encourage
and uh those wretched five million or so
people who stubbornly have refused to be
vaccinated at all because they believe
all this complete
rubbish that's on the internet from the
anti-vaxx conspiracies who are doing a
great disservice to this country so
we've just got to keep talking up the
jab talking up the booster and i've
still got this horrible vision in my
mind anna of kevin mcguire and office
christmas party brandishing that piece
of mistletoe he was talking about
really worrying
kevin has it been cute
from my lawyer
i just
just made me feel very uncomfortable i'm
sure it made you feel even more
uncomfortable anna yeah well we saw the
telegraph there the eyes also got the
same story but let's talking of
christmas parties let's go to the
mirrorfront page which is day two willie
for pippa crearer uh your political
editor and the revelations of what may
or may not have happened in downey
street just before christmas last year
um before the lockdown obviously but we
were we were sort of tier three tier
four territory here rule of six we all
you know we all remember it like some
bad dream don't we uh booze nibbles and
party games until the early hours um
what what sort of denial did we get from
the prime minister today kevin on this
well prime prices questions he didn't
deny the parties went on three times he
had a chance to do it three times he he
didn't he just said the rules were
followed but he always does that do you
remember he claimed the rules were
followed in uh the hospital in hecks of
northumberland but he wasn't wearing a
mask and it turned out the rules weren't
followed and he then had to admit he he
broke it even if he said very very
briefly
the liaison committee later he said i
very briefly you know went from one
place to the other and forgot to put it
on so it was it was like human error
moment for him that was his
justification for that anyway can't
carry on yeah well yeah just he's he
didn't wear a mask in a hospital where
he's required then he was seen not
wearing a mask on a train and then he
wasn't wearing a mask in a theater and
he was photographed doing it after uh
people in the field have been
specifically asked to to wear it this
this question with boris johnson that
he's the ruler he makes the rules for
the rules he doesn't follow himself it's
very it's very dangerous it's very
damaging because it undermines the rules
itself but it creates a resentment that
he thinks he is above
uh the regulations and the restrictions
on everybody else's as his life and when
he says the rules were followed it just
does not look like the rules were
they're having those parties in downing
street where other people were at the
bedsides of relatives who were dying it
wasn't just a matter of they they
couldn't have parties themselves uh so i
think this is real this is really
damaging and he's just not honest about
it but then again he's not really honest
about anything is it he's the the worst
liar as a prime minister uh
it's certainly a living memory and
probably in history yeah just and just
quickly sort of via that story to andrew
just um the front bench of the
conservative party at pmq's today
wearing masks i read i have to admit i
forgot to stare at them to check uh
including jacob rees-mogg who has really
been one who who does not choose to wear
them uh but your thoughts on whether
this is damaging this idea of what's
going on in downing street a year ago
i think it is a bit but i don't think
it's i think it's nothing like uh the
completely egregious breach of the rules
of dominic cummings driving up to durham
and then driving his family to the
beauty spot of barnard castle that was
clear
horrible appalling breach of the rules
and the la and the and the fibs that
were told about eyesight tests and all
the rest of it just made me ill really
and people didn't believe a word of it
the problem with this story is
apparently the prime minister certainly
wasn't at one of the parties and i don't
think he was at either of them so um
but these and people are at work they're
already in work it's not as if they've
got left their homes to go to a party
specifically now perhaps it was a breach
of the rules because you weren't we
weren't supposed to socialize but we
weren't quite in lockdown yet i think
it's fuzzy and grey and it doesn't look
great but i don't think this is a really
bad bad breach in the way but as i say
barnard castle was or even worse the
hideous site of matt hancock what he was
doing to that woman his aide in a
horrible break of the rules in that
video we're never going to ever escape
the memory of that awful video are we
ever ever that was a really bad
breakthrough should we just have a rule
not to not to raise that one again to
get out okay i think we just have to
explain to matt hancock what hands uh
face space mean it doesn't mean you've
yeah you've got your body and your hands
over somebody else's face and
invade their faces
mistletoe yeah well exactly yeah who
needs mistletoe whatever month it was
i've forgotten now um but let's move on
to the daily telegraph and the eye and
for anybody hoping that this is going to
be over soon from the ordering process
of of jabs it appears not the eye for
example booster jabs ordered until 2023
uh bitten by britain buys another 114
million vaccine doses clearly we're
planning for this to be a long-term
project and indeed the virus you know
continuing through next year at this
rate kevin
yeah no absolutely it's like it's it's
here to stay up or the government thinks
it is and it's gonna continue mutating
uh it's not gonna go away and
vaccinations jabs are on the front line
of
trying to beat it up at the very least
cope with it as
the restrictions are really pretty
minimal at the moment in terms of
wearing masks uh isolated if you come
into contact with somebody somebody who
had um omicron in the return of the you
know the red list for flights and uh
tests on day two after you've uh you
you've arrived but my only worry about
this i think in some ways it's very it's
very sensible to plan ahead and an order
the modern and the fires of vaccines are
being used for these extra jobs but if
we take all the vaccine supplies what's
going to happen to those other countries
around the world that have less money
and can't come by them in the same way
and where we just see now we're we live
in an interdependent world the
government likes to call us global
britain
um well we're in the globe and if we're
taking all the vaccines and hogging them
and buying them and storing them some of
them are being wasted and not used then
we're never going to beat this virus
because you have to beat it around the
world it's that lying i think gordon
brown and the former liber prime
minister popularized saying um nobody's
safe until everybody's safe there is a
truth in that
president macron and uh prime minister
johnson um once again having a bit of a
spat tell us more
yeah this is the front page of the
telegraph and they've got
a french newspaper i've forgotten which
one has revealed that president macron
has described boris johnson as a clown i
think he probably called him a lot worse
than that and uh and he blames all of
his problems with boris on brexit but we
know what boris thinks well i don't know
what i think about macron really is a
hissy prissy little diva who throw is
still throwing his toys out of the pram
can't come to terms with brexit can't
come to terms with the fact that a lot
of people in france are becoming more
and more eurosceptic he really is a
ghastly little creature and you see they
banned pretty patel from those talks
last sunday in calais then french have
now agreed to have talks with pretty
patel it's pathetic his posturing is
ridiculous he is a silly little man
who's very worried about his
presidential election next year and i
hope this new bloke who's come in who's
uh done his prospects no harm whatsoever
at the age of 68 it turns out he's
having a baby with his pa who's about a
third of his age that'll do wonders for
his prospects in the french election
there's a french like that sort of thing
yeah but it's split it's just like some
voters it's a baby out of um a wedlock
do you yeah but yeah look
let's blow your champion there with a
baby
he's a horrible audience racist uh you
you would not you would not like macron
odious too
but
macron and johnson are made for each
other in in many ways calling johnson a
clown johnson can't reach for lawyers
and sue can he because he is a clown i
think i think matt would also call him a
knucklehead which i think is also uh the
case and he said it's a tragedy that a
great country like ours britain is being
led by this clown and knucklehead i
think he's also right on that lots of
criticisms of mackerel absolutely he's
fighting an election himself and he
faces questions uh and migrants crossing
the channel but we face questions too
and the government lies when it says
most of them are economic migrants
because the government's own figures
show more than 70 of them all refugees
are entitled to claim uh asylum here so
yeah you can have a go at macron but
think of johnson too and if we're
talking about throwing toys out of the
pram andrew you do it all the time it
must be
a rage suggestion
i mean you have boxes and boxes of toys
and you're probably chugging them all
the time rattles dolls
plastic
noisy things well in the meantime the ft
reporting that the us is throwing said
toys uh and delaying a deal to remove uh
trump-era tariffs on uk steeler
aluminium because they're worried about
northern ireland and brexit andrew just
quickly
what's he got to do with him what's he
going to do with the president of the
united states we should keep his nose
out he's got so many problems of his own
uh biden this is just a cheap floyd to
try and shore up the vote with the irish
americans in places like new york where
the democrats are diving in popularity
because the city is so highly taxed um
the these these were the terrorists that
matt that that trump imposed on northern
ireland steel they were meant to be
coming off and now he's threatening to
keep them there a bit longer while the
arguments go on over the northern
ireland protocol but those arguments
about the northern ireland protocol will
be resolved i imagine in the next week
or so